Let me show you what happened when the
woman dishonored her role and chose to
lead man. Now you guys want to see what
happens when the woman usurps the role
over man and man becomes passive and
allows the woman to lead against God's
ordained structure and hierarchy. You
want to see what happens?
You guys want to see from Genesis
3? You sure? You're going to get blown
away. You're going to get blown away.
But we're going to need to go to the
King James Bible. You must have the King
James Bible. Get ready to be blown away
reading Genesis 3:es 1-7. Are you ready?
Okay. Now, watch here. Now, why this is
important? Genesis 3, let's read verses
105. Let's read Genesis 3:es 1 and5
first. Now the serpent was more subtle
than any beast of the field which the
Lord had made. The Lord God had made.
Now watch. And he said unto the woman,
"Yay, hath God said, pay attention to
the pronoun. Ye shall not eat of every
tree of the garden." Notice the ye. Pay
attention. Okay? You got to pay
attention or you're not going to catch
this.
And the woman said unto the serpent, we
notice we, Adam and I, we made eat of
the fruit of the trees of the garden,
but of the fruit, fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden. God
has said, ye, notice the pronoun, it's
why again, ye shall not eat of it.
Neither shall ye touch it, lest ye die.
Notice the Y, that's two or more. Now
watch here, verse four and five. Okay?
And the serpent said unto the woman,
"Ye," notice, it's why again, "Ye, who's
he talking to? Ye shall not surely die.
For God doth know that in the day ye,
not thou, ye, eat thereof, then your
eyes shall be open, and ye shall be as
gods, knowing good and evil." Okay, did
you catch the why? Ye, your eyes. You
remember in King James and Dewey resigns
the Y is plural. You, Ye, your, two or
more. Two or more. Okay, did you catch
it? And in case you're not catching it,
do me a favor. Do me a favor. First last
post Genesis 3:3 with Genesis 2 15-1 17
back to back. Watch the difference now.
Genesis 3:3 with Genesis 2 15-1 17 back
to
back. Watch the
difference. But of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden, God
has said, "Ye shall not eat of it,
neither shall ye touch it, lest ye die."
Now notice the difference. "And the Lord
God took the man and put him into the
garden of Eden to dress it and keep it.
And the Lord God commanded man, saying,
"Of every tree of the garden, thou
mayest freely eat." Notice it's thou,
not you, but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil, thou shalt
not eat of it. For the day that thou
eatest thereof, thou shalt surely die.
Do you see now why you can't give up on
your King James Bible?
Why you I say in my estimation I believe
it's God's perfect words in English
preserved by
God. Why is it in Genesis 2 15-17 it's
singular thou? He's only talking to
Adam. Can anyone tell
me? Why is he only talking to
Adam? Can anyone tell
me? Yeah. If you don't know the original
languages, King James will be perfect.
Because there was no Eve. Come on, guys.
We just read it. Eve wasn't
created. Eve was created after God
instructed Adam. It was only Adam.
That's why it's
thou. Don't you
remember Genesis 2:15-1 17? And then 18
then he creates. What's wrong with you
guys? You see, you do not pay attention.
Why do you think I repeat myself over
and over and over again and I get tough
with you guys and sometimes I scream?
Not because I hate you. Because short
attention
spans. You don't pay attention. You
don't meditate and therefore it doesn't
sink in. And that's why there's a high
level of biblical
illiteracy. There was no Eve when God
told Adam the
following. But you understand the
difference. Let's look at it
again. Genesis 2:es 15-1 17 with Genesis
3:3 back to
back. And the Lord God, read with me.
And the Lord God took the man and put
him into the Garden of Eden to dress it
and to keep it. The Lord God commanded
the man, saying, of every tree of the
garden, thou mayest freely eat, but of
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil, thou shalt not eat of it. For in
the day that thou eatest thereof, thou
shalt surely die. Now notice Genesis
3:3. This is now Eve speaking to the
serpent. But of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden, God
hath said, Ye shall not eat of it,
neither shall ye touch it, lest ye die.
Do you see the difference in the
pronouns? You see the difference in the
pronouns?
Yeah, Muhammad Ib Daw.
Exactly. Don't go ahead of me yet. No,
filet. How is she
mistaken? Have mercy on
us. So, let me get this. God told Adam,
"Don't eat of it, but it's okay for Eve
to eat of it." Of course, Eve can't eat
of it. Where was she wrong? If God
forbade Adam to eat, then of course
that's going to apply to his wife who
later joins him. Why would Eve be wrong?
If God is telling Adam, "Don't eat of
it." You think Eve is exempt? Of course,
she can't eat of
it. So, she's right. Neither Adam nor me
can eat. Neither Adam or me can
touch because we'll both die. It applies
to me as
well. You get it?
Okay,
now I don't know if you really caught it
though. Let's look at it again. Let's go
to Genesis 3:es 3:5. Genesis 3:es
3:5 one more time. Let's see you catch
it. Now you saw the why. Why it's
important, right guys? Pay attention. No
side talks, no side tangents, no
debates. Focus. But of the fruit of the
tree which is in the midst of the
garden, God has said, "Ye shall not eat
of it, neither shall ye touch it, lest
ye die." Now pay attention to the
serpent. Can I ask you who who the
serpent is talking to? Tell me who the
serpent is talking to. And the serpent
said unto the woman, "Ye," he didn't
say, "Thou ye shall not surely die. For
God doth know that in the day ye eat
thereof, then your eye shall be open,
and ye shall be as gods, knowing good
and evil. Can I ask you a question?
Although he's talking to Eve, who's he
actually
addressing? You got it, Shammer. Footus,
you got it. Disobey every day. You got
it. That means although he's talking to
Eve, Adam is there and he's talking to
her and addressing both of them as he's
talking to her. You got it? That's
another mystery that's now going to open
your eyes. You got it.
Now he's having conversation with Eve,
but Adam is there hearing the
conversation. So he's saying
look you guys won't die cuz God knows
that when you guys eat your eyes will be
open. You get it
now? And if you want further proof Adam
is there
listening. Let's read Genesis 3 6 and 7
cuz you're going to see where I'm going
with
this. Exactly. April 1st I want to kiss
your head. That was the part Eve usurped
authority over Adam and Adam remained a
passive observer instead of stepping in
and taking control of the sin. You got
it. April 1st, you see the
sin.
Aha. You guys got
it. Genesis 3
6-7. You got it. Arthur Lewis. See, now
the light switch went
ding. You got
it. Genesis
3:6-7. Let's read it again. And when the
woman saw that the tree was good for,
notice the woman started desiring it.
Where does sin arise? In your heart. It
starts with a desire that's contrary to
God's will. And then you act upon the
desire. So it started with looking. When
she saw the
food pleasant in
eyes, and desired to make one wise,
right, the fruit thereof, and did eat,
and gave also unto her husband with her.
So she he was there. She ate and gave
and he was right there. Did you catch
it? With her and he did eat. And the
eyes of them both were open and they
knew that they were naked. Did you catch
it?
You caught it now? So, what's the
sin? Now, let me break down to you the
sin that started in the
garden. The serpent initiated
conversation with the woman. And the
woman responded back instead of having
Adam step in, take over the
conversation, and then silence the
serpent and protect his wife from his
satanic deception. In other words, the
woman took control of the situation and
Adam allowed her to take control and
remained a passive observer, thereby
reversing the role and failing to lead
the situation as her head and protect
her from his satanic
deception. That was the sin. You get it?
The sin of the woman assuming the role
of the husband and the husband allowing
her to assume that role, remaining a
passive
observer and allowing her to lead
instead of him leading her and
protecting her from the serpent. That
was a
sin. And notice the serpent's strategy.
Notice what he did. He went to the
woman, not to the man, in order to pit
the woman against the man, by having her
lead and assume the role assigned to her
husband, thereby destroying the
hierarchy set within the family. So
notice that Satan's number one attack
was on the word of God and the family
structure. Notice the two things that
that Satan attacked from the get-go.
Getting you to doubt God's word and
destroying the family structure. And
that's what he's been doing ever since
till this
day. Yep. Nothing new under the sun.
History repeats
itself. Are you catching it? Is it
sinking
in? He got them to doubt the word of
God. And what is one of the major
attacks in destroying the Christian
faith? Get you to doubt that the Bible
is inspired, reliable, trustworthy,
preserve the word of
God. And the other attack was to destroy
the family unit, the hierarchy set
within the family to pit the woman
against the man and the man against the
woman, which he does till this day.
The same mo modus operand
die. You catching it
now? Eating the
fruit was the culmination of that sinful
desire that already rose within their
hearts and minds.
So you
understand the man
failed in his
duty,
right? He was the one who was supposed
to take the lead, step in and say, "Hold
on. No, she's my
wife, right? And she's under my headship
and my protection." And he should have
said, "Eve, what are you doing? Don't
entertain
his
suggestions. I heard from God and I'm
telling you this is what God said and
we're going to honor God. Get away from
us. You're a liar and a
deceiver because God told me and God
cannot lie because I know God and I know
he's a God of truth. Get away from my
wife and Abe. Don't even entertain any
thought that he's telling you the truth.
Instead, he sat back, let the serpents
engage his wife, and his wife engaged
the serpent and then did what the wife
wanted to do instead of stopping her,
preventing her from eating the fruit,
protecting her, and guarding
her and obeying God. That's what you
got.